Trascrizione: Alessandra Tadiotto
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Albert Einstein amava dire
che quando un problema sembra insolubile
è perché lo stiamo affrontando
con le premesse sbagliate.
Oggi nella scienza c'è un problema,
che è difficilissimo.
È così difficile, che è soprannominato
l' "Hard Problem" per antonomasia.
Questo problema non riguarda
l'origine dell'Universo,
è un problema che riguarda noi stessi.
Che cosa siamo? Dove siamo?
Nel mondo fisico, noi dove ci troviamo?
Le neuroscienze, negli ultimi 100 anni,
si sono concentrate soprattutto
sul corpo, sul cervello.
Hanno cercato la cosa che noi siamo
dentro il nostro sistema nervoso.
Eppure, 150 anni
di ricerche delle neuroscienze
finora non hanno trovato niente
che assomigli alla nostra esperienza
dentro il sistema nervoso.
Nessuno,
neanche con le tecniche più sofisticate
di brain imaging oggi a disposizione,
ha mai trovato dentro il nostro cervello
qualcosa di simile alla nostra esperienza.
E allora, come diceva Einstein,
forse dobbiamo mettere in discussione
le premesse sulle quali abbiamo basato
anni e anni di ricerca scientifica
sulla coscienza.
Forse la coscienza,
la nostra esperienza fenomenica,
i colori che vediamo,
i sapori che proviamo,
non si trovano dentro il cervello.
Ma dove si possono trovare?
Io vi chiedo di prendere in mano
quella mela che avete trovato
sulla vostra sedia
e di guardarla, di toccarla.
In questo momento voi fate -
state facendo esperienza
di questo oggetto.
Questa cosa, così semplice,
in realtà è un mistero per la scienza,
perché ciò che voi trovate
nella vostra esperienza
nessun neuroscienziarto
è riuscito a trovarlo
dentro questo oggetto meraviglioso
che è il cervello.
E oggi le neuroscienze
non sanno rispondere
a questa domanda:
come il cervello
possa creare al suo interno
questa cosa che è
la vostra esperienza della mela.
E allora io vi propongo
di prendere in considerazione
un'ipotesi radicale,
che all'inizio vi potrebbe
apparire bizzarra,
ma forse non è così strana come sembra.
In questo momento,
voi state toccando la mela;
e la vedete.
E se io vi chiedessi:
"Descrivetemi cosa trovate
nella vostra esperienza della mela,"
voi mi direte, "Io faccio esperienza,
e nella mia esperienza c'è il rosso,
c'è il lucido, c'è il rotondo,
c'è la struttura della mela."
Non c'è niente del genere,
dentro il cervello.
E allora ecco l'ipotesi che prendiamo
in considerazione oggi:
e se la cosa che è
la nostra esperienza della mela
fosse la mela stessa?
E se noi fossimo, letteralmente,
fuori dal nostro corpo,
e se questo oggetto che teniamo in mano,
in questo momento,
fosse la base fisica,
la cosa che è identica con noi stessi?
Se voi ci pensate,
questa ipotesi semplifica moltissimo
la domanda su dove siamo e cosa siamo.
Siamo un mondo, siamo un oggetto:
non siamo dietro agli occhi
e in mezzo alle orecchie,
ma siamo davanti al nostro corpo.
Bene, questa idea, in realtà,
si scontra con due obiezioni fondamentali,
che sono il motivo per cui le neuroscienze
han cercato dentro il sistema nervoso
la nostra esperienza,
e le affronteremo insieme.
Il primo problema da cui partiremo
è la cosidetta "variabilità soggettiva",
cioè il fatto che questa mela
può apparire diversa a ciascuno di noi.
La mela può apparire
di un rosso vivace a me,
ma se qualcuno è daltonico,
appare di un rosso molto meno vivo.
Può sembrare fredda
se ho tenuto le mani in un luogo caldo;
può sembrare calda se ho tenuto le mani
in una bacinella gelata.
E per spiegare questa
variabilità della mela,
nel passato si è ipotizzato
che esistesse una mela
e tutti facessimo
delle esperienze soggettive,
e quindi andavano collocate nella mente.
Ma non è necessariamente vero.
Il mondo, la mela -
e non la nostra esperienza della mela,
ma la mela stessa -
è molto più ricca di quanto non crediamo.
Prendiamo in considerazione
una proprietà semplice della mela:
la velocità.
Questa mela, in questo momento,
è ferma o si sta muovendo?
Questa mela è ferma
rispetto al palcoscenico,
ma si sta muovendo rispetto
a degli oggetti,
come un'aereo, come una macchina,
che sono in movimento
rispetto a questa stanza.
Quindi questa mela,
per quanto può sembrare strano,
ed è dal tempo di Galileo che lo sappiamo,
è sia in movimento sia ferma;
anzi, questa mela,
per quanto possa sembrare strano,
si sta muovendo in tutte le direzioni,
perché esistono infiniti oggetti
che si stanno muovendo -
le molecole dell'aria, i pianeti,
gli aerei, le macchine -
e quindi questa mela ha infinite velocità,
anche se noi ne possiamo
vedere soltanto una.
Ma lo stesso ragionamento vale
anche per altre proprietà.
Prendiamo il colore.
Guardate questo quadrato alle mie spalle.
Vi potrebbe sembrare più o meno bianco,
come gli schermi dei calcolatori
quando vogliono produrre il bianco;
ma se voi vi avvicinate,
voi vedrete che in realtà è una griglia
di puntini rossi, verdi e blu,
il cosiddetto bayer grid.
È bianca, o è una griglia
di punti colorati?
E la risposta è che è bianca
relativamente a un corpo umano
a più di un metro di distanza,
ed è colorata
relativamente a un corpo umano
a pochi centimetri di distanza,
oppure un corpo diverso,
magari l'occhio di un'aquila
che è dotato di una risoluzione
molto più elevata.
Prendiamo in cosiderazione un oggetto
leggermente più complesso:
il tramonto.
Io vengo dalla Liguria,
qui alle mi spalle vedete
la spiaggia di Lavagna al tramonto.
Il tramonto è un oggetto
che esiste in modo diverso
per ciascuno dei corpi
che si muovono sulla spiaggia.
E infatti, due persone
in due posti diversi
fotograferanno due tramonti dversi.
E il tramonto si sposta
se noi ci spostiamo.
Il tramonto esiste
relativamente al nostro corpo.
È possibile estendere
lo stesso ragionamento
per tutte le proprietà della mela,
e mostrare che la mela
non esiste in assoluto,
ma la mela esiste relativamente.
Quindi l'idea ingenua
da cui eravamo partiti,
secondo cui,
di fronte alle diverse
esperienze della mela,
solo una è la vera mela,
in realtà non è
scientificamente giustificata.
Non è vero che esiste una mela
e tutte le altre sono
esperienze soggettive.
Esistono tante mele
quante le nostre esperienze,
così come questa mela ha tante velocità
quanti oggetti in movimento
ci sono in questa stanza.
Ha tanti colori quanti sistemi
interagiscono con lei.
Quindi, in una frase,
noi non vediamo una mela
in 100 modi diversil,
se qui siamo in 100.
Ma vediamo 100 mele diverse,
perché ognuna di queste mele esiste
relativamente a ciascuno dei vostri corpi.
E questo risolverebbe il problema
della variabilità della soggettività.
Non è più la soggettività
ad essere variabile,
ma è il mondo che è relativo.
Però dobbiamo affrontare
un altro problema molto grave,
per questa ipotesi che vi ho presentato.
Quando noi facciamo
esperienza della mela
e la mela non c'è, come nel sogno
o nelle allucinazioni,
non è la prova che quello che vediamo
non esiste nel mondo fisico
ed è una creazione del cervello?
In realtà, se noi guardiamo
ai sogni e alle allucinazioni,
noi troveremo che sono chimerici.
Voi sapete, la chimera
era una creatura fantastica
che era costruita
mettendo insieme tre animali.
In maniera analoga, i nostri sogni
sono una composizione
della nostra vita passata,
ma non contengono mai
nessun elemento radicalmente nuovo.
Avete mai sognato un colore
che non avete mai visto?
Avete mai sognato
un componente elementare,
una dimensione geometrica
che va oltre le nostre tre dimensioni?
No.
I nostri sogni non creano, ma ricombinano.
Sì, però voi direte,
"Va bene che i sogni ricombinano:
però la mela, quando dormo,
non c'è, anche se la sogno.
E allora?"
E allora, come suggerito
all'inizio da Einstein,
dobbiamo fare un passo indietro
e considerare anche il tempo,
cioè la nostra idea ingenua di presente.
La mela, qui e adesso,
è nel nostro presente?
Relativamente,
perché la mela è tra 15 e 300 millisecondi
prima dell'attività nel mio cervello,
perché la luce impiega tempo
a raggiungere la mia retina,
i fotorecettori impiegano tempo
e così via.
E che dire della Luna?
Si trova a 1,3 secondi,
che è una mela un po' più lontana.
Che dire del Sole?
E che dire delle costellazioni?
Sì, lo so, ci hanno sempre detto
che le costellazioni, quando le vediamo,
potrebbero non esistere più,
perché la luce impiega anni
e la stella potrebbe essere già esplosa.
Son sempre catastrofisti, gli astronomi.
Ma, in realtà, anche la mela
potrebbe non esistere più
quando la vediamo,
se uno la mangiasse nei 300 millisecondi
che i processi fisici impiegano
ad arrivare al nostro cervello.
Tutti questi esempi ci mostrano
come il nostro presente, in realtà,
sia esteso nel tempo.
Il nostro presente non è un punto,
è qualcosa che si distribuisce
in una estensione temporale.
E questo non solo
nella memoria, nel sogno;
ma anche nella percezione.
Basta uscire fuori, sedersi su un prato,
guardare il sole, guardare le stelle
e il nostro presente si estende
per minuti, ore, decine di anni.
E allora l'ipotesi qual è?
L'ipotesi è che, nel sogno,
noi siamo isolati
da questo presente prossimo
e cominciamo a percepire
in combinazioni, le più varie,
il nostro passato, la nostra vita.
Che si ripresenta a noi in modo chimerico,
ma senza aggiungere niente
di radicalmente nuovo.
E da questo punto di vista, quindi,
i sogni sarebbero
una percezione del passato.
In conclusione,
nella scacchiera spazio-temporale,
che è la casa della scienza,
noi abbiamo due oggetti:
l'oggetto esterno, la mela;
e il corpo, il cervello.
Quale di questi due oggetti
è la cosa che noi siamo?
Le neuroscienze finora
hanno cercato, senza trovarla,
la nostra esperienza dentro il cervello.
E se fosse l'oggetto esterno?
E se fosse la mela?
Questa ipotesi ci permette di superare
i limiti dell'antropocentrismo,
che si riflettono nell'idea
che il centro della nostra esistenza
sia il nostro corpo.
È ancora una forma di antropocentrismo,
è ancora l'idea che l'uomo,
rappresentato idealmente
da Leonardo da Vinci,
dall'uomo vitruviano,
sia al centro dell'universo.
Invece, forse, la cosa che siamo
non è il nostro corpo,
ma è il mondo esterno.
Forse l'uomo non è
al centro dell'universo,
come Darwin e Copernico hanno dimostrato
in due importanti occasioni.
Forse al centro della realtà
c'è la realtà stessa,
che esiste relativamente ai nostri corpi,
che la fanno esistere
in tanti modi diversi.
Non perché siano speciali,
ma perché partecipano alla realtà.
Quindi il messaggio
che vi voglio dare, oggi
è che forse noi non siamo neuroni,
non siamo informazione dentro il cervello,
ma noi siamo mondo.
Siamo nuvola, siamo cielo.
Siamo realtà.
Grazie.
(Applausi)